we sure Elijah Wood what are you doing
in Austin I'm here to cover South by
Southwest for movieclips that's cool
I don't know Austin that well I happen
to know it pretty well would you mind
taking me to a few of your favorite
spots I would love that
this is one of your favorite spots in
uncommon objects yeah why do you love
this store so much well it's just an
incredible mixture of uncommon objects I
like to just come in here and explore
and kind of get lost the thing I love
about uncommon objects too is that the
aesthetic they really take care and
curating it and like the way it looks so
you know Austin pretty well I do what is
it that you like about Austin what makes
it different it's a place where I feel
like crazy ideas are supported there's a
sense of community here it is a big city
it feels like a small town and you've
got two films playing yeah yes two very
different movie yes you must be lucky to
have films but it's incredible yeah and
also on either side of the sort of
things that I do one is something that I
produced yeah one is something that I'm
in which is really cool should we go to
spot number two let's do it
all right so we're here at end of
veneers which is my favorite record
store in Austin this is what I start
always where I started
what is this the new arrivals great
record I mean honestly I I kind of come
here for anything so in addition to
selling CDs vinyl this is the sort of
like rare wall cassettes
there are labels now that are only
releasing things on the stack when did
you get into DJing um it was actually I
love music so much the idea of being
being able to play music that I love to
a lot of people was exciting things I
just started doing it as a hobby and I
eventually moved into might know there's
one more let's go to church
YAG one of your favorite spots in Austin
yes why should I say it's your favorite
number one favorite spot I think it is
yeah it feels like home it's the Alamo
Drafthouse but people have never been to
the draft house yeah how do you sum up
the vibe or what makes it special apart
from the fact that you can get pickles
and fried pickles milkshakes I don't
know it's a combination of being able to
order a drink have a meal yep but also
be in a sacred space by the way we need
to pay attention to this we're walking
through a monster's mouth those are all
Alamo employees so there's loads of it's
kind of like Easter eggs you can spot
the Alamo employees and you can come and
be on the shining come shining carpet
play with us Danny there's a sort of
love of cinema kind of everywhere you
walk here everywhere you learn and I
love that you can come here get tickets
and you can also get a beer
yes adults like hopefully there's a
thing here of genuine enthusiasm for a
number like a multitude of things it's
not just music it's not just film it's
kind of whatever you're into it and that
is bringing it all back everything is
sort of the defining aspect of Austin
it's a place for enthusiasm where the
thing you love will be supported and
you'll find a group of people who love
it too getting emotional talking about
it possibly that's but that's a really
that's an it's a very important aspect
of this place Elijah Wood thank you so
much for joining Lisa Malone thank you
you can stay tuned to our South by
Southwest coverage every single day all
right here on movieclips I'm Alicia
Malone